pigs are flying on this chilly day
inhale as fred barnes reports in The
Wall Street Journal that the Democrat
Party may be moving slightly to the
right on abortion we'll analyze then
Jacob Airy and His Eminence Paul Bois
are on an all-male panel of deplorable
'he's just to punish me and we will
discuss banana peel microaggressions
Charlie Hebdo is calling Harvey victims
Nazis and how cops only kill black
people I'm Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're gonna have the mailbag today too
so thank you for everybody who sent in a
mailbag question we have lots of good
ones to get to what I really want to
talk about today is this vote yesterday
at the LA City Council to rename
Columbus Day as indigenous peoples day
it was used by it so it few things
offend me more than renaming Columbus
Day it is anti historical it is morally
idiotic it is empty virtue signaling it
really drives me crazy it's ungrateful
but I want to dedicate an entire episode
to defending Christopher so we'll do
that closer to grew at Columbus Day and
today we have to talk about this great
abortion story pigs are clearly flying
in hell so this is a welcome change and
a pretty unexpected one after the 2016
DNC platform position on this issue I'll
tell you I thought even at the time even
at the time I thought that was an
extreme position and it moved pretty far
after just in 2008 Hillary Clinton had a
very different view on on abortion we
can support a woman's right to choose
that makes abortion safe legal and rare
and reduces the number of abortions it's
amazing to think that that was just in
2008 Hillary Clinton said abortion
should be safe legal and rare which of
course doesn't make any sense if
abortion is morally similar to murder
then it shouldn't be legal and if it's
not morally similar to murder if it's
just a procedure to remove a part of
your body then there's no reason that it
should be rare but classic Clintonian
example of saying two things that have
different sides of your mouth
by 2016 not many years later the Planned
Parenthood was selling baby parts to the
highest bidder and the Democratic Party
was cheering them on pretty sure that
you actually take
just tissue that first apology or you
can find it exactly right what what is
what we can use what is intact so that's
why I'm saying no don't lowball I want
you to be happy were those undercover
Planned Parenthood sting videos I want a
Lamborghini don't we all those videos
they are almost cartoonishly evil
they're really just to the core evil
it's amazing that some Hollywood
screenwriter if a Hollywood screenwriter
had written that and turned it in well
forget the politics of Hollywood but if
he had turned it in for a movie about
this it would be thrown out for being
too on-the-nose that a woman is going to
sell body parts and haggle over the
price so that they could make more of a
profit it sounds like a horror film it
died actually it sounds like a horror
film and so in May Nancy Pelosi came out
and suggested that the Democratic Party
would support candidates who weren't
strictly in favor of abortion if there
were some candidate who's a Democrat and
all the other ways but as pro-life they
would consider giving them money
Pelosi wants that big tent as they call
it Chuck Schumer came out and said that
he's in favor of that big tent
even governor Moonbeam our own governor
here in California the the once and
future Governor Jerry Brown he came out
in favor of supporting pro-life
candidates but the former DNC chairman
and failed presidential candidate had a
less favorable view of that let's cut to
Howard Dean for his reaction not happy
he did not support that move at all he
said that he would not donate to
candidates who were pro-life he would
not support those candidates he wants to
keep the the Democratic Party pretty
small now Planned Parenthood CEO is
Cecile Richards along with NIR all and
all of the other pro-life advocacy
organizations were predictably
infuriated here's her reaction
I thought I was gonna make it through
that with that breaking it is amazing
that they put her on TV
she's so unlikable I don't know why they
would ever put her on TV like that now
why are the Democrats doing this there
are two words Donald Trump Donald Trump
won five states that the Democrats have
won four to two elections in a row Brock
Obama won all five of these states twice
Iowa Michigan Ohio Pennsylvania and
Wisconsin those happen to be states
where social issues matter and it turns
out that you have just the devil going
on TV it's the board of your candidates
it doesn't play that well in Peoria now
Republicans are basically unified on
this issue 68% of Republicans are
pro-life and that is the same for men
and women 68 percent of men 68 percent
of women interestingly the more educated
a Republican is the more likely he is to
support pro-life the more likely he is
to oppose abortion a 71% of college
graduates who are Republican or pro-life
the number dips down a little bit below
for a postgraduate degrees but the trend
line is is obviously in favor of
pro-life as Republicans are more
educated Democrats are totally split on
this issue Democrat a pro-life according
to Gallup is 32% men are 35% women or
30% so Democrat manners are more likely
to be pro-life and women as Democrats
are more educated that number actually
decreases though for a pro-life and 29%
of white Democrats are pro-life but 39%
of black Democrats of pro-life so that
the minority vote that Democrats are
always sucking up to and pandering to
actually opposes their rigidity on the
issue of abortion now this presents a
real problem for Democrats because a lot
of their issue in the last election was
that they came across as elitist out of
touch with the regular American Hillary
Clinton wanted to kill
they seem to toss the issues of the
middle class in the lower classes
completely out the window to suck up to
Hollywood celebrities and to suck up to
the the latte-sipping limousine liberals
did not play well for them and though in
particularly in those five states so the
March for Life has been getting larger
every year things have been moving in
the direction of pro-life anyway but the
country remains split on it this is this
is great for us for the country and for
Republicans in particular for two
reasons there's the moral reason if the
Democrats are supporting pro-life
candidates that means that we'll
probably get more pro-life politicians
politicians who are less likely to be
extremists on the issue of abortion on
the political issue though it will split
Democrats so if we can wedge an issue in
there with them then Republicans are
more likely to win those elections and
Republicans generally are more pro-life
anyway so it's a win-win situation to
discuss this we have to bring on our
all-male panel of deplorable z-- I
figure when we're discussing an issue
like abortion it's very important to
only talk to men so we have we have
Jacob Airy from The Daily wire and of
course his Eminence Paul Bois to give us
his opinion on it Jacob
lots of people could take credit here
president Trump could take credit those
undercover Planned Parenthood video
creators could take credit
Trump's reaching out to new voter
demographics we could give them some
credit who deserves all of the glory for
making the Democrats give up it or move
slightly to the right of their currently
sacramental view of abortion I honestly
think it's actually pro-life democrats
who deserve some credit for this i have
several friends who they vote they are
in principle democrats but they vote
republican because of the life issue
they they they can't stand Cecile
Richards they can't stand Planned
Parenthood they know the backstory of
Margaret Sanger a radical racist who
wanted to exterminate the Negro
population her words and I I think that
they gets they shouldn't receive some of
the credit because they've been pushing
this party in this direction after they
after they left it so I really feel that
they when they voted for Trump they said
hey we want
our voices to be heard and we have to
get trump elected we're gonna do this
you bring up a great point in Margaret
Sanger people should read woman in the
new race that's that's an essay by her
book by her that does sum up this really
spooky eugenicist position on abortion
but there yeah there there is a lot of
glory to go around on moving Democrats a
little bit back to moderation on this
issue publi his your eminence when did
Democrats begin to take this sacrament
of you of abortion it wasn't so long ago
that pro-life democrats were welcomed in
the parties and i right
no no no no actually not the democrats
pretty much adopted abortion into their
platforms in 1976 and 1980 and of course
Mondale was pro-abortion and so was
Dukakis Jimmy Carter actually however
expressed several times even long after
his presidency that he regretted
enforcing roe v wade and so there was a
climate of kind of that big tank
pro-life democrats are allowed in the
party and it wasn't really until 1992 at
the democratic convention when the
Clintons disinvited I do remember the
Clintons being around in 92 yes yes and
the Clintons disinvited Pennsylvania
Governor Robert Casey from speaking at
the convention in Robert Casey was a
big-time pro-life Democrat and he was a
big time member of the party he was his
name Casey was the Casey in the famous
Supreme Court decision Planned
Parenthood v Casey so by having him get
disinvited that was really when the new
trend of the abortion litmus test set
into the party should you blame the
Clinton in that way yeah it's the
Clintons and I think them getting
defeated is a wonderful thing and it may
end that a litmus test finally I'm happy
to blame the Clintons for everything
that that's perfectly fine with me we
have to move on to much more important
issues than the sanctity of life and
human dignity a Greek life retreat at
Ole Miss was canceled this weekend after
a banana peel was found in a tree a
student tossed the perfectly compostable
banana peel because he couldn't find it
garbage-can now according to the
director of Greek life my quote many
members of our community were hurt
frightened and upset by what occurred a
banana peel being tossed into a tree and
felt it was imperative to provide space
immediately to students affected by this
incident Pawa who is at fault here is
that the parents is that the
administrators is it the students
themselves is hit our terrible culture
Michael I I'm just at a loss here I'm
just gonna go ahead and say it's the
banana peel really I typically on all of
these triggering cases these
microaggressions I find them ridiculous
like and at least somewhat see the point
or the flow of logic that they're making
this I'm at a loss so I'm going to say
it's the bananas fault we should just
ban all bananas they're racist I agree
my favorite fruit Jacob how do we fix
the problem of snow flakiness it is
really fun to make fun of these people
they're out of their minds if they're
triggered because some kid threw away a
banana peel but how do we fix it how do
we make students stronger and smarter
and and less out of their minds I think
the solution should be we should teach
Western culture from a literary
perspective I mean if you read a lot of
like Charles Dickens the the masculine
and the feminine characters are all very
strong but here's but because these
faculties placate to these snowflakes
they're like oh well Dickens Shakespeare
on and on and on they must be racist
because they're written by straight
white men or whatever and so I think my
doubts about Dickens but sure but my but
I'm just saying if we if we go back to
teaching oh this is how if we go back to
teaching that literature we we presented
them good moral strong characters I
think that they can be strong again it
should go it should go back to teaching
what their Western culture is all about
then you have to read though it's a
Dickens is very projects I'm one of the
few Millennials who reads I guess you
know absent you are and that's how it's
gonna stay
you make me sick I don't have time for
that stuff okay we need to say goodbye
to Facebook and YouTube now and I know
that what you're waiting for is to hear
more of this panel I know that you want
to get a blessing from His Eminence
Beaubois but you can't do that unless
you go to the daily wire.com right now
and subscribe we want to thank all of
the current subscribers it helps us keep
the lights on in here it helps us keep
refilling our leftist ears tumblers full
of delicious salty leftist tears but if
you haven't done that yet go over there
it's $10 a month hundred dollars a year
you get my show you get the Andrew
Klavan show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get the leftist ears tumblr keeps
your leftist ears hot or cold always
salty and delicious it's a really great
deal frankly folks we make the best
deals over here so go to daily wire.com
right now and we'll be right back
[Music]
the latest cover of the French satire
magazine Charlie Hebdo reads God exists
he drowned all the neo-nazis in Texas
the editors at Charlie Hebdo might
remember that their stupid magazine
would be written in German if it weren't
for us Paul
surprise surprise Muslim terrorists
murdered much of the Charlie Hebdo staff
the United States is leading the global
fight against radical Islam but these
children over there these rude people
have decided to attack us they've
decided to attack regular Americans
why won't they give us a break and is
there any satirical merit to making fun
of hurricane victims well the reason why
they won't give us a break Michael is
because they're leftists at heart I mean
I know we want to give them credit and
they were attacked and that was a
horrible horrible thing and we all
rightly stood alongside them and they
were brave enough to criticize Islam
when everybody is running away from that
issue but it doesn't change the fact
that they've just been nothing but cruel
and merciless towards Christianity and
particularly Catholicism and the way
they've painted it on their magazine and
on the issue of whether or not you know
you can do satire and hurricane victims
look you can do satire on anything so
long as it's tactful and it's funny I
mean even that stupid political cartoon
that was making fun of the hurricane
victims at least had a little bit of
tact in there this is just dead dead on
arrival it's not funny it's not tactful
it's akin to the Kathy Griffin holding
Donald Trump's you severed head it's
it's just a tasteless cartoon it's also
a little ridiculous of them Jacob do
they do the French have any credibility
to call Americans Nazis Hitler sneezed
and those guys surrendered is there any
credibility to their accusations
absolutely not and I want to make
something absolutely clear to Charlie
Hebdo when you were attacked by radical
Muslims Texas Monthly didn't put a cover
didn't put them cover mocking France on
on their publication absolutely
not and you know what 750,000 Texans
went to World War two and rescued you so
I don't even want to hear and 22,000 of
them died my sister she is literally
trapped by a flood of water my
great-grandmother is in a nursing home
and they're trying to keep the power on
so those nursing home attendant are
those missing home living patients don't
die so shame on you Charlie Hebdo I am
disgusted by this I'm offended as a
Texan and you should apologize
immediately this is the first time I've
ever seen Jacob berry angry and you were
you really got to do a lot to get Jacob
very angry I'm sort of aroused great job
charlie hebdo you've you've done the
impossible you rude French dummies okay
that's it I gotta get oh no I'm sorry
there is one more story there's one word
great story we have to cover body cam
footage has just surfaced of an incident
last year in an Atlanta suburb when a
woman pulled over for drunk driving told
the officer that she didn't want to get
out of her car because she'd seen so
many videos of cops killing people the
officer responded but you're not black
remember we only shoot black people we
only kill black people right all the
videos you've seen have you seen the
black people getting killed not maybe
not the classiest joke the officer could
have made Paul left wing heads have
exploded here is the outrage justified
over these comments I mean look Michael
you know I'm very very quick to condemn
snowflakes and all of their phony
outrage but this is definitely one I
mean I know that the officer is joking
and clearly is not clearly joking right
I think some people yeah I could see
there though I mean if I'm a black
person and I hear officers saying like
we only shoot black people yeah I could
understand the initial outrage don't
think the guy should lose his job no but
I'm gonna cut some people having
outraged a little bit of slack on this
one that's Barry you think that you'll
cross the line I wondered a little bit
it is a funny joke though because
I think people think that he's joking
about black people being killed by the
cops that's clearly not it he's joking
about the narrative that is being pushed
there have been study after study that
has come out that has explained a way
most of the disparities between black
people and black suspects being killed
by cops and suspects of other
ethnicities and I think the narrative
here is that there is a nationwide
epidemic of racist cops go looking for
the next black person to kill which is
just simply untrue and if the joke is
about that
I kind of cut him some slack on it it
seems to me that cops have been under a
lot of attack over the last few years
nevertheless not the sort of thing that
one should say professionally and
especially not when you're in a position
of enforcing violence and coercion Jacob
the officer was placed on administrative
leave is that too harsh for a joke or
does that punishment fit the crime I
think in this case the punishment does
fit the crime I don't think he should be
fired I don't think that he should be
removed as a police officer but
administrative leave especially since it
was just such as Paul was talking
earlier it was it was a joke that lacked
tack and I agree with you it was a
little it was a little yeah very lacking
a lot of tact and I agree with you it
was a little funny because he was just
kind of being sarcastic but I still
think that yeah he's a police officer he
he he should honor his badge and he and
I think in this case he dishonored it so
administrative leave I think is just
right for him two jokes that just simply
did not land for people you gotta watch
your comedy guys okay panel you're out
of here Jacob your eminence
thank you very much for coming on now we
have to get to the mailbag all right
first question comes from Mike just
discovered you here on Daily wire I'm a
new subscriber and former leftist thanks
for coming on over both to The Daily
wire and to the right love your work but
why the heck is your book not available
on Kindle you know that this there's a
big misconception about this my book is
preloaded on every single Kindle what
you have to do is you take it out and
you make
that the book is powered off and you can
read it cover-to-cover but thank you for
your support
from Tyler hey Michael would you and
Ruben be willing to speak at a community
college and if so what would be the best
way to set up the event we would love to
do that
LeAnn only speak for myself but I love
speaking at colleges and would love to
come to your college so if you want to
do that just tweet at me and I will
connect you to the people who handle
that and we'll set it up it'll be a lot
of fun from Brandon
dearest Michael trolls best cigar under
fifty bucks
thanks kind regards finally a question I
care about I have been doing this show
for a month now and I haven't gotten a
question that I care about nearly as
month nearly as much there are a couple
categories here if you're able to get
Cuban cigars if you're traveling to Cuba
or you're traveling abroad there are a
number of great Cubans under fifty bucks
the prices vary widely so if you go to
Cuba the cigars are dirt cheap if you go
to London you'll have to mortgage your
house to afford any of them for the
Cuban cigars I would recommend that
Trinidad via the same Luis Rey exclusive
Oh Cuba and the boulevard bella cosa fee
no all tremendous cigars could be cigar
of the year for non Cubans I would
recommend which are available anywhere
in the United States I've been smoking
them for years and years and years I
would recommend my father basically
anything by them the blender is Don
Peppino everything he makes is exquisite
the padrone 1926 aniversario in 1964
anniversary are both good I prefer the
1926 it's a little pricey but it's an
excellent cigar I love Nat Sherman
cigars I'm from New York it's a New York
local tobacconist the timeless series is
very good if you can get your hands on
the Gotham west side that's my favorite
that they put out and then of course
Oliva
series V and Series O or tremendous
cigars I recommend them they're really
cheap they're like seven or eight bucks
a stick and I couldn't recommend them
more I've been smoking them since I was
a wee little boy next question from
David mr. Noles who would you pick to
star in a movie adaptation of your
number one bestseller David is talking
of course about reasons to vote for
Democrats a comprehensive guide I
recently rewatched gone with
wind and I think I would have to use an
actor from that film specifically the
wind the scene that comes to my mind is
from American Beauty
it's that scene where the wind is
whipping around and there's a little
plastic bag just floating around and the
kid he says this is my greatest work of
art when I consider all of the reasons
to vote for Democrats and that is the
picture that I see before me and I would
love it if a Hollywood director could
realize my artistic vision for that film
from George hi mr. Knowles I'm not sure
if you saw in the news recently that
Iceland is on the path to completely
eliminating Down syndrome from its
population through prenatal screening
and abortion I think we actually
mentioned this on the show a little bit
we did we do at least on a panel this
seems very Nazi asked to me it is
especially since people born with Down
syndrome could still have a high quality
of life they can how would you argue
with someone who thinks this is a good
thing I would ask them specifically who
would you kill of the people who are
alive right now who have injuries who
are maimed who have been amputated who
have mental retardation of any variety I
would I would ask them which of those
people would you kill for whom would it
be better to be dead than to be alive
and I think that will shut them up and
make them realize the flaw in this
argument because in Iceland and for
other eugenicist arguments here with a
center their arguments around is
abortion because of the fiction that if
you kill a baby in the womb
it hasn't really lived yet and you're
not killing it you're just preventing it
from ever having life but the reason we
know that that little baby has Down
syndrome in the womb is because it's a
little baby that is living that we can
run tests on and figure out what their
life will look like to some degree after
they're born so I would I would make it
very clear that you are ending a life
and if we go down this path if we say
well people with Down syndrome they
shouldn't live their life is so poor it
which is not true by the way but they'll
say their life is so poor it's not worth
living for them then you have to ask
well how where do we draw that line do
we say that people who are born with
limbs their quality of life will be too
poor people who are born with autism
their quality of life will be too poor
people who are born with a predilection
for the common cold is that will their
life be too poor when we determine who
has the right to live and who ought to
live based on how beautiful they are how
smart they are or how tall and
athletically strong they are we're going
down a really bad path
that will will end in Oblivion and
despair from Hendrick in California I
unfortunately overheard two men
discussing the killing of trees which
leads me to the following questions if
they are distressed about the murder of
trees what do they eat for breakfast did
they commit abortion by eating eggs or
did they commit infanticide by eating
alfalfa sprouts excellent questions
Hendrick I got this a lot with my blank
book because environmentalists would
yell at me for wasting all of this paper
you must remind them paper is an organic
renewable resource we should use it we
should print out these emails and that
way the tree farms won't just become big
parking lots in the middle of Washington
State this does call to mind my favorite
group of political activists they are
the people who are vegan they're crunchy
they're vegetarian but they support
abortion those are two things that
cannot go together there there people
who what they won't eat an egg because
chicken life is sacred but they will
kill a second or third trimester human
baby because human life is not sacred
does not make a whole lot of sense
perhaps you should bring that up to them
from James good day Michael good day
James here in Australia we're having
this same-sex marriage debate and I was
wondering what are the best secular
arguments for and against gay marriage
PS would you ever like to visit
Australia PPS keep up the great work
PS yes PPS thank you very much the gay
marriage debate it has been totally
wrongly framed on both sides but in
particular on the left people view this
issue as a civil rights issue who has
the right to get married why do some
people have the right to get married but
some people don't have the right to get
married I can marry any woman that I
like any person that I love but as
someone who's gay can't marry the person
that they love this is skipping the
first question in this debate
is what is marriage and that's not
necessarily a religious question
obviously religions have quite a lot to
say about that but it's a philosophical
question it's an historical question
it's a question that has always had
basically one answer for the history of
civilization which is that marriage is a
union between one man and women at least
women there there has been polygamy at
various points in in our history but for
the vast majority of that history it's
been between one man and one woman and
so the secular question that you can ask
the philosophic question is what is
marriage why is marriage why do we think
of it as between a man and women or a
man and one woman is there something
about the complementarity of the sexes
that defines marriage is the sexual
difference inherent in what marriage is
does marriage involve the possibility
the potential to create a family the
atomic unit of society if marriage is
not about that if marriage is simply
about sexual attraction or emotional
attraction then why on earth would we
prevent polygamous couples from being
married polyamorous couples from being
married why would we prevent marriages
that involve more than 50 people if it's
simply about attraction and living
together and visiting people in
hospitals and any other order of things
that could be accomplished simply
through contract law if the sexes are
different if there are inherent sexual
differences and if those inherent sexual
differences play some part in our nature
and in our society then the question of
redefining marriage is a perilous one
and should be taken very cautiously and
not oversimplified as it has been at all
levels right up to Anthony Kennedy
giving one of the stupidest decisions in
the history of the Supreme Court and
saying that the only reason to oppose
gay marriage is irrational hatred of
gays it's slanderous and absolutely
absurd next question
from Lucy hey Michael you often joke
about your Catholic guilt and seem to be
ripping into Joel Osteen for his focus
on mental positivity I hadn't heard of
Osteen aside from the name aside from
the time he was on Jimmy Fallon show but
at first glance I would say his self
talk style of preaching has both
scientific and biblical foundation
a perhaps cliche but obvious example
being Philippians 4:8 do you think
Christians are supposed to live ashamed
what's your take on Romans 8:1 and
Galatians 5:1 cheers Lucy
I actually don't mean to rip into Joel
Osteen as a figure in the culture or as
a book writer or as a TV host I do rip
into him a little bit as the leader of
the largest church in America but as a
figure I don't think he's necessarily
doing anything particularly wrong let's
go through those Bible verses that you
brought up Philippians 4:8 finally
brothers and sisters whatever is true
whatever is noble whatever is right
whatever is pure whatever is lovely
whatever is admirable if anything is
excellent or praiseworthy think about
such things wonderful advice we ought to
do it all the time
Romans 8:1 therefore there is now no
condemnation for those who are in Christ
Jesus also true Galatians 5:1
it is for freedom that Christ has set us
free stand firm then and do not let
yourselves be burdened again by a yoke
of slavery and Christ Himself tells us
this in the Gospels follow me for my
yoke is easy and my burden is light
all of which is absolutely true and
Christians should live joyously and
joyfully you rarely see a frowning st.
you see Saints who suffer all the time
but they don't seem to be frowning too
much because they're filled with joy
even when they're grieving or if they're
a little sad
we sure certainly shouldn't live a shame
we should live in joy in Christ and this
is the issue with Osteen is that Osteen
does not talk about Christ very much in
his sermons or on his Twitter account he
used the word Jesus or Christ 112 times
out of over 16,000 tweets he doesn't
have a cross on his altar in in his mega
church so practically go with what works
if Joel Osteen is giving you practical
advice for your life which is by the way
what he says he's doing he says he's not
an evangelist in the traditional sense
and I give him total credit for honesty
if that's helping you in a practical way
go with it go with what works
theologically though I wouldn't focus on
you a lot of old Osteen's books are
living your best life now making the
better you you you you and a man wrapped
up in himself makes a very small package
indeed
you should do is live joyously looking
at Christ as all of those verses allude
to so I would make sure that we don't
focus on sentimentality here I think
that's what Osteen kind of goes into a
little bit jesus wept
it's the shortest verse in the in the
New Testament Jesus wept and he wept
rightly so your freedom was purchased
miraculously at a great cost it was
purchased at the cost of God the son
being incarnate and dying on the cross
being tortured infinitely literally
dying and then coming back up three days
later now when you think about why he
died and the reason for what he died
which is the sin of mankind
I guess that's negative that's probably
not the most positive thing to think
about but when you think about it in
that way then the miracle of redemption
is much more awesome it fills you with
greater awe and it fills you with a
deeper and truer joy so I think we ought
to view the world in exactly that way we
ought to smile just as much as Joel
Osteen if that's how the spirit moves us
but it shouldn't be one that's based on
saccharine or sentimentality because the
CS Lewis points out in the weight of
glory if you look for truth you might
find comfort but if you look for comfort
you'll find neither truth nor comfort
only soft soap and wishful thinking and
in the end despair so ground it in
something real and look toward Christ
for that rather than toward yourself and
now the final question from Greg Michael
the Clavin aid that's a nice nickname
I'm excited for your new story podcast
that you're working on with Andy
millennial he's so in touch with our
culture isn't he just raps about what
all the kids are talking about like rock
and roll and stuff but I do have one
concern since this takes place in
another universe will this introduce
Clavin into a new universe only to pull
him out every week making a dr i say bum
bum bum Clavin --less weekend thank you
that is a really serious concern thank
you for bringing up a philosophical
question a paradox that has plagued drew
and i since we began working on this
this story podcast another kingdom my
answer to that is it's in another
universe who cares it's not in our
universe
not my problem I don't care thank you
for that question we'll let you know
more when that Park
is about to come out now we are heading
into the Clavin this weekend so batten
down the hatches get the MREs and the
ammo ready we will be back next Monday
tune in then I'm Michael Knowles this is
the Michael nul show have a good weekend
stay safe
[Music]
you
[Music]